Guten Tag, ich bin Dr. Mert, ich bin zuständiger als für Sie.
Ich möchte heute mit Ihnen über Ihre Beschwerden sprechen, aber so als brauche ich ein paar persönliche andaten, dann sprechen wir genau über Ihre Beschwerden.
Wie lautet Ihr Name? Guten Tag, hallo. Wie ist Ihr Name bitte nochmal?
Ich bin Dr. Mert. Mert. Ja, ein schöner Name, ja hallo.
Danke schön. Wie lautet Ihr Name?
Mein Name ist Alois Gandolf.
Können Sie Ihren Nachname buchstabieren?
Mein Nachname ist Gandolf, Gustav Antonopoul, Dora Ottolutwick Friedrich Gandolf.
Und Ihr Name bitte? Alois Anton Lutwick Otto Ida Siegried.
Herr Gandolf, ja. Jawoll. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 36 Jahre alt. 36 Jahre alt. Wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Sie wollen mein Geburtstatem müssen. Ich bin am 25. Februar 1987.
Sie sind 85 Jahre alt. Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie, Herr Gandolf?
Ich bin 1,85 Meter und wiege 92 kg. 1,85 Meter groß, 92 kg schwer, ja.
Sind Sie gegern COVID-19 geimpft? Nein, wollte keine Impfung.
Ich empfehle Ihnen, Impfung zu lassen, aber...
Ja, Herr Doktor, aber das will ich nicht. Nein, nein.
Wie viele Sachen können Sie noch mal sprechen?
Ich möchte keine Impfung.
Ich verstehe Sie ganz gut. Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Also, Herr Doktor Merz, ich habe seit circa...
Ja, das sind jetzt schon 10 Tage ungefähr Kopfschmerzen,
ich habe mir durch die Augen weh und ich bekomme keine Luft über die Nase.
Und das wird immer schlimmer.
Okay, wie stark sind Sie?
Auch wenn Sie nicht telefonieren, sind Sie sehr stark.
Also, das ist sehr unterschiedlich.
Ich meine, ich sehe es mehr, mal weniger, aber ich denke, das Schlimmste war,
jetzt nach Ihrer Skala zu beantworten, vielleicht 5 oder 6.
Könnten Sie diese ein bisschen weiter genau beschreiben,
die Schlimmersten, Herr Pulsierant, Drücklerant, oder einseitig, beidesseitig?
Also, das hat es erst einseitig angefangen auf die linken Seite.
Aber ich würde das eher als Drück in der Schmerz bezeichnen.
Jetzt ist es aber auf beiden Seiten.
Okay, beidesseitig.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser?
Kann ich nicht sagen, aber jedes Mal werde ich meinen Kopf nach vorne beuge
oder irgendwie drehe, dann wird es noch schlimmer.
Haben Sie dagegen einen eleganten Verschwemmingdekument eingenommen?
Bisher eigentlich nicht, ich dachte, das geht von alleine weg,
aber ich habe ein bisschen inhaliert und so Kochsalzlösung in der Nase probiert,
aber das hat alles nichts gebracht.
Okay, waren Sie deswegen schon bei Mars?
Ja, noch nicht, deswegen bin ich heute zu Ihnen gekommen,
das geht von alleine weg, aber das wird Ihnen jetzt seit zwei, drei Tagen noch schlimmer.
Okay, ich trage den Schmerz in einem anderen Körperteil aus.
Es ist mehr hier vorne am Kopf und an den Sternen.
Okay, alles klar.
Husten Sie, Herr Gondor?
Seit gestern ist ein bisschen Husten dabei.
Haben Sie Ausbruch bemerkt?
Nein, also ich komme nichts raus, das ist eher sein Trockenhaus.
Trücken, Husten.
Haben Sie Piper?
Das weiß ich nicht, ich glaube ja, seit zwei Tagen glaube ich, ich habe sie jetzt nicht gemessen,
aber ich fühle mich sehr warm an.
Wie wird es denn Sie oft, oder?
In den letzten Tagen immer mehr, ja, aber ansonsten nicht.
Okay, bekommen Sie sich über Luft?
Ja, also ich bekomme eigentlich fast gar keine Luft, ja, ich kann nicht schlafen.
Meine Nase ist komplett zu und zu langsam habe ich auch schon Halsschmerzen.
Haben Sie selbst Covid-19 Test gemacht?
Nein, habe ich nicht gemacht.
Okay, gibt es jemanden in Ihrer Umgebung der gleiche oder ähnliche Symptomen hat oder Beschwerden hat?
Nein, ansichtlich nicht, ich bin der einzige.
Hab ich Sie noch eine Beschwerdung?
Herr Gondor.
Was meinen Sie mit anderen Beschwerden?
Das ist genug, ich meine.
Ich bin der Gewecht.
Sie haben schon viele Beschwerder erwähnt, aber das ist ja eine schöne Frage.
Ach so, ja, also seit heute merke ich, dass auch mein rechtes Ohr auch ein bisschen leh tut.
Seit wann haben Sie recht an Ohrschmerzen?
Seit gestern.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Gut, bisher eigentlich ganz gut, aber wir haben jetzt in den letzten Tagen jetzt wirklich schlecht.
Okay, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder zurückgenommen?
Nein, eigentlich alles gleich geblieben.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stilgang oder was anderes?
Nein, bisher nicht, alles gut.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie unter Insomnia leidet, unter Einschlafstörung leidet wegen dieser Beschwerden.
Ja, aber davor haben Sie irgendwelche Einschlafstörungen oder Durchschlafstörungen?
Nein, nein, war nicht wahr, das ist wie Nordklinik.
Okay, Herr Gandolf, ich würde mit Ihnen über Ihre Vorerkrankung sprechen, aber davor nötigen Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, was kann das sein? Ich habe jetzt ein bisschen langsam Angst bekommen.
Es ist jetzt Migräne oder ist es etwas anderes, aber irgendetwas geht das nicht weg.
Ich befürchte, dass es halt noch schlimmer wird. Ich möchte, dass Sie mir helfen.
Ich befürchte Sie ganz gut, Herr Gandolf, aber machen Sie Sie keine Sorge.
Ich würde Ihnen ein paar Vorerkrankungen über Ihre Vorerkrankungen fragen, stellen.
Aber nach dem Einpferuntersuchung, dann kann ich Ihnen genau sagen, was Sie haben, aber im Moment machen Sie Sie keine Sorge.
Leiden Sie an Ihre Vorerkrankungen?
Nein, aber mein Haushalt hat gemeint, dass ich einen leicht erhöhten Blutdruck habe, das wir beobachten sollten.
Bisher habe ich noch keine Medikamente, aber...
Seit wann leiden Sie an Blutdruck?
Das ist wohl kein hoher Blutdruck, aber seit zwei Jahren glaube ich.
Seit zwei Jahren? Leiden Sie noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Nein, alles ganz gut.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente ein?
Bisher noch nicht, nein. Also keine Regenmäßigen.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Operation ja, ich hatte mal eine Knieverletzung, eine Sportverletzung.
Und da hat ich Menuscus rys auf der rechten Seite und das musste operiert werden.
Ist Operation Kontrerasion aus Verlöpfung?
Das war alles ganz gut, ja.
Sind Sie aus dem Dorf konferiert worden?
Aus einem anderen Grund? Nein.
Wurden Ihnen schon die Stationen aufgenommen?
Nein, wie gesagt nur wegen der Knie.
Alles klar. Sind bei Ihnen Allergien?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Allergien ist, aber Polenallergie habe ich dann immer im Frühjahr.
Und so eine leichte Laktose, Unverträglichkeit, aber das ist jetzt nicht schlimm.
Wie ist das für Polenallergien?
Ich bekomme immer so Tränen in den Augen, ich muss nie sind.
Und dann juckt es überall in der Nase.
Aber da hilft mir dieses Zettirizin ganz gut.
Dann nehme ich das ein paar Wochen lang und dann ist das in Ordnung.
Alles klar.
Wie ist das für eine Laktose, Unverträglichkeit?
Wie gesagt, das ist jetzt nicht schlimm.
Immer wenn ich ein bisschen Kakao oder Mehl trinke, oder so Joghurtprodukte zu mir nehme,
dann bekomme ich so leichte Blähungen.
Manchmal einen gleichen Durchfall, aber es ist wie gesagt jetzt nicht so schlimm.
Ich verstehe Sie.
Sind bei Ihnen noch andere Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Nein, nicht, dass ich möchte.
Rauchen Sie Herr Gandolf?
Nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja.
Was trinken Sie oft?
Ich trinke gerne mal ein Bier.
Und manchmal auch mal ein Rotwein.
Rotwein.
Trinken Sie ein Plastik Bier pro Monat oder pro Woche?
Und ich würde mal sagen, 2-3 Mal die Woche.
2-3 Mal pro Woche.
Alles klar.
Wie viel trinken Sie Rotwein?
Das ist bei gleich mal die Woche so ein Gläschenwein.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Drogen?
Drogen?
Nein.
Was denken Sie denn?
Das ist nur Routine-Pleige Herr Gandolf.
Ich dachte schon, das wäre gern habe ich gefragt.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe eine kleine Tochter, sie ist 2 Jahre alt.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja, wir wissen sie sehr lebendig.
Gott sei Dank, das ist gut.
Wir leben Sie mit Ihrer Familie zusammen, ja?
Ja, das waren Frauen, sich mit unserem kleinen Tocher.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Informatiker.
Ich arbeite in der IT-Branche.
Ich bin in einer größeren Firma für die IT-Zuständig.
Für die IT-Sicherheit.
Das ist gut Herr Bildhof.
Sind Sie sich das ausgesetzt?
Ja, natürlich.
Der Job ist schon sehr stressig.
Wie ist das für Sie?
Ich möchte es, aber ich schaffe es nicht immer.
Wenn ich es kann, dann gehe ich mal Fußball spielen.
Das mag ich gerne.
Ich fahre manchmal mit dem Fahrrad zur Arbeit.
Jetzt kommen wir zur Familiengeschichte.
Gibt es in der Familie irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen?
Was hat das mit der Erkrankung zu tun?
Einige Vorerkrankungen von Vater oder Mutter,
Hand von ihrer Beschwerden oder ihrer Erkrankung.
Deswegen müssen wir immer nachfragen.
Okay.
Gibt es in der Familie irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen?
Ich habe meinen Vater, der ist ein Kind.
Er leitet Diabetes und nimmt Medikamente.
Wie spenden Sie den Typ?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Er hat das seit ein paar Jahren.
Ich glaube, das nennt sich Altersdiabetes.
Er hat einen hohen Blutbruch.
Er nimmt seit sehr vielen Jahren Tabetten.
Aber welche sind, weiß ich nicht.
Beide Mutter?
Meine Mutter hat typische Frauenerkrankungen.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, sie hat eine Blasenschwäche.
Was meinst du mit Blasenschwäche?
Ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht.
Die kann ihren Urin nicht halten.
Aber sie ist eine Schwester?
Nein.
Sie haben mir gesagt, dass sie seit zehn Tagen
Kopfschirmatschen besonders vorne und Augen schirmatschen.
Diese Schmerzen treten einseitig auf.
Jetzt haben sie beide Seite und drücken die Schmerzen.
Außer dann leiden sie unter Atemnot
und laufen die Verstopfe Nase.
Verstopfe Nase?
Sie fühlen sich fieberig, aber sie haben das Fieber nicht gemessen.
Sie schwitzen Hofstärke oft.
Sie schlafen wegen dieser Beschwerden nicht gut.
Das war meine Frage.
Haben Sie eine Frage?
Nein, danke.
Ich möchte geholfen haben.
Ich wäre Ihnen dankbar, wenn Sie mir sagen können, was es ist.
Eigentlich kann ich nicht genau sagen, was Sie haben.
Ich brauche auch Einfache und Untersuchungen.
Ich habe auch eine Sinusitis umgangssperlig
neben Nasennebenhöhe der Entzündung.
Das kann schon sein.
Aber ich muss beschätten, dafür brauche ich ein paar Untersuchungen.
Alles klar.
Es dauert lange, aber ich habe auch eine Sinusitis.
Ich würde Sie körperlich untersuchen, dann Blut abnehmen.
Dann führe ich einen Covid-19 durch.
Je nach Ergebnisse können Sie zu Hause gehen.
Alles klar.
Das scheint, dass ich relativ schnell nach Hause komme.
Ich bin sehr froh, weil ich möchte nicht im Haus gehen.
Ich möchte nicht im Haus gehen.
Sie sind in guter Hand.
Vielen Dank.
Ich habe Kollegen und andere Fragen.
Keine Fragen?
Ja.
Sie haben eine Frage.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja?
Schön.
Haben Sie bemerkt, wenn Sie Ihren Kopf vorne beugen,
eine Schmerzen haben?
Ja, das habe ich ja gesagt. Wenn ich meinen Kopf nach vorne beuge,
dann habe ich das Gefühl, dass meine Augen rauskommen.
Da ist so ein Druck.
Okay, jetzt ein paar Ergebnisse vielleicht.
Untersuchungsergebnisse, Herr Doktor.
Sie haben Blut abgenommen.
Da sieht man ein hohes CAP von 65.
Blutbild leicht erhöht mit Leukosythen von 12.
Niere ist gut, Labor ist gut, Schildrüsewerte sind auch gut.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung merken Sie,
dass die Nerven-Austrittspunkte hier und da sehr schmerzhaft sind.
Auf beiden Seiten. Die Nase ist verschlossen.
Im Hals der Rachen ist sehr stark gerötet.
Die Schildrüse und die Silen sind geschwollen.
Sauerstoff-Sättigung ist gut.
Fieber 38,2.
Ja.
Ich habe hier einen kleinen
Anruf.
Hallo, guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Wir haben einen neuen Patient, nämlich Aloys Gran, dort.
Ich würde über ihn berichten, darf ich?
Aber natürlich, Herr Doktor.
Dann fangen Sie mal an.
Sie sind noch der neue Arzt aus der Türkei, oder?
Ja, genau.
Wie ist Ihr Name noch mal, bitte?
Ich bin Doktor Merth.
Der Merth, ja, natürlich.
Und Ihnen habe ich schon sehr viel gehört.
Dann erzählen Sie mal bitte, was haben Sie untersucht?
Herr Gondolf ist 36 Jahre alt, 1,85 m groß,
92 kg schwer.
Herr Gondolf stellt sich heute bei uns wegen seit 10 Tagen
Bescheidte-Händer einseitige Kopfschirmassen vor.
Die Interstate der Schirmassen bewertet
erst auf einer Schirmastik von 5 von 10.
Er beschreibt diese Schirmassen erst seit 10 Tagen.
Er hat sich heute bei uns wegen seit 10 Tagen
bescheidte-Händer eine freundliche Schirmastik von 5 von 10.
Er beschreibt diese Schirmassen erst einseitig,
dann beideseitig und drückendere Frontale.
Laut dem Patienten sind die Bescheiden langsam aufgetreten
und im Laufe der Zeit schiedenmäher geworden.
Er hat als Begleitsymptome noch beide Spiele.
Er hat erst einmal rechte Oah schmerzt.
Er hat sich darüber ausgeführt,
dass er seit gestern Bescheidte-Händer rechte Oah schmerzt.
Er hat über ausstrahlende Schmerzen in das rechte Oah.
Das ist auch richtig.
Als Vorerkrankungen leidet er seit zwei Jahren
an Atelierhypertonie.
Er nimmt keine Medikamente.
Er nimmt Seteris in Beiberdark.
Er ist wegen Meniskus Verleitzungsrechts operiert worden.
Er ist allergisch gegen Polen.
Diese Allergie äußert sich mit Rhinoconjunktuitis.
Außerdem ist bei ihm Laktos Intoleranz bekannt.
Er ist mit Rhinoconjunktuitis und Konjunktivitis am besten.
Konjunktivitis bedeutet das eine insündliche Prozess.
Er ist mit Laktos Intoleranz bekannt.
Er ist mit Rhinoconjunktivitis und Konjunktivitis am besten.
Er ist verheiratet und hat eine Tochter.
Seine Tochter ist gesund.
Er ist Informatiker von Beruf.
Er leidet unter Viehstress.
Der Vater des Patienten leidet an die Abethesmelitus II.
Die Mutter des Patienten leidet an Hyrnär in Kontinas.
Im Status müssen wir sagen, er ist gegen 19.
Die Analystische Angabe deutern am ehesten auf Rhinoconjunktuitis und Akute Tonzylitis.
Was hat der Patient, Ihre Ansicht nach?
Was ist der Schnelltest?
Negativ.
Was war das mit dem Ohr?
Was ist das jetzt?
Eigentlich ist die Schmerzen recht ein Ohr aus.
Das kommt vom Hals.
Haben Sie das Ohr in die Schmerzen reingeschaut?
Ja, ich habe beide körperliche Untersuchungen schon untersucht.
Die Gehörgänge sind frei und das Trommelfälle ist unaufwändig?
Ja.
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten?
Nach der Überprüfung der Vitalparameter würde ich körperliche Untersuchungen durchführen.
Aber wir haben schon das gemacht.
Ich würde Blut abnehmen.
Danach würde ich PCR-Test durchführen.
Was?
PCR-Test gegen COVID-19.
Das ist eine Covid-Entwicklung.
Was machen Sie?
Die Patient hat seit über 10 Tagen beschwerben.
Die Nase ist verschlossen.
Sie hat starke Kopfschmerzen.
Manche Untersuchungen würden Sie noch machen am Kopf?
Ich würde auch Röntgen und die Geherne bei den Fals CT veranlassen.
Sehr gut.
Als ein Röntgen der Nase nebenhüllen, das sieht man sehr gut.
Und gegebenenfalls eine CT-Untersuchung.
Man muss sich vielleicht eine Entlastung vornehmen.
Das kann sich nicht von alleine sich lösen.
Was für Medikamente oder welche Therapie empfehlen Sie den Patienten?
Nach der Beschäftigung meiner Verdachtung würde ich eine Antipelatik und Anallgätik
für eine Antipelatik, die Sie nach RRG beschreiben.
Das ist schon klar.
Was geben Sie gegen die Nase?
Für die Nase ist es zu.
Was für eine Nase ist zu?
Ein Cortison-Spray.
Ein Cortison-Spray?
Das ist nicht richtig.
Aber keine Linitis.
Salzhaltigerlösung.
Das hatte doch schon benutzt, die Salzhaltigerlösung.
Das hat doch bisher nichts gebracht.
Ganz einfach.
Sie geben ihm ein abschwellendes Nasenspray.
Abschwellendes Nasenspray?
Abschwellendes Nasenspray.
Welches ist das? Welche Wirkstoff?
Wie weißt du, haben wir einen Hinoa-Arzt unter uns.
Silometazolin.
Sergo, Silometazolin.
Das ist also das klassische Nasenspray.
Das soll die Poren öffnen.
Jetzt will ich sagen, dass wir das nicht länger als 3-4 Tage benutzen,
weil es auch die Schleim heute austrocknen kann.
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Wir haben uns in dieser akuten Phase.
Sie brauchen erst mal ein abschwellendes Nasenspray.
Wenn die Nase offen ist,
können Sie eine Kochsalzlösung oder eine Nasenspülung machen,
damit der Schleim sich auch entleeren kann.
Was geben Sie denn noch?
Was empfehlen Sie noch?
Ich empfehle der körperliche Schonung.
Was noch für die Nasen?
Dass der Schleim sich richtig löst.
Was geben Sie den Patienten noch?
Schleimlöser.
Welches Medikament geben Sie?
Ein Mucolytychum.
Das ist der Schleimlöser.
Welches Wirkstoff?
Welches Medikament?
Welche Medikamenten?
Ich habe die Kollegen, die können helfen.
Ambroxol.
Ambroxol ist sehr gut.
Ein Kabiloge hilft dir.
Ambroxol als Medikament.
Oder ACC als Bräusetablete.
Was machen Sie noch?
Hier sieht man ein T.
Was geben Sie noch?
Ein einfacher Hausmethode.
Inhalieren.
Warme Dampf.
Einatmen löst auch den Schleim.
Welches Antibiotikum?
Welches Antibiotikum hilft bei einem Infekt?
Der oberen Atemwege.
Ich würde das so als Medikament.
Welches Penicillin ist gut?
Amoxicillin.
Welche Dosierung?
Einthausend Medikamenten.
Wie oft nimmt man das am Tag?
Zweimal.
Dreimal täglich.
Amoxicillin.
Amoxiclav kann man auch geben.
Aber eigentlich würde man so ein breites, wirkendes Penicillin.
Was machen Sie, wenn der Patient eine Penicillin allergiert hätte?
Ich würde Claritromis in der Schreibung.
Claritromis.
Oder ein Makrolit.
Sehr gut.
Wunderbar.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Ja, ich habe noch Fragen.
Danke schön.
Sie haben das schon sehr gut gemacht.
Vielen Dank.
Das freut mich.
Ich glaube, Sie werden die Prüfung sehr gut bestehen.
Ich habe es.